what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing our coverage on Dark
Knight's metal we get into the origin of
the Devastator Devastator batman
basically doomsday Batman and it's
really really cool you keep in mind all
these origin stories and you'll notice
this with the playlist down in the
description all the stories or all these
origins basically come out of issues
number two and number three but it is
still pretty cool to see all this stuff
unfold because when it comes to the
Devastator it's just this doomsday based
Batman is really all it is but it's
really cool because it asks the question
what would happen if Batman became
doomsday now keep in mind in like the
casting in The Forge one of the things
that DC established is that the tuning
fork from Infinite Crisis was still
there a little bit of history guys when
it came to Infinite Crisis it was
basically the rebirth of the multiverse
is really all it was but the way in
which this was done was by a version of
lex luthor from a different universe
basically constructing these sort of
tuning force which is to say these
pillars that would lead to the creation
of the multiverse by harnessing like
cosmic energies more or less now i dealt
with like the anti-monitor different
things like that but the whole idea was
that after Infinite Crisis was over and
the tuning fork was destroyed we never
really saw it again there was no reason
to believe that it ever existed it just
kind of seemed like a one-time you know
device that was there that served a
particular purpose and that was it what
the casting in the Forge revealed was
that the tuning fork was still around
that Batman had taken it or something
along those lines and it was being held
in a Fortress of Solitude
the tuning fork basically allows its
wielder to channel all these different
cosmic entities of a higher being into
the fork itself and then control the
very nature of reality to do virtually
anything they want to you with it and so
what this does is it comes out of the
tasks assigned to Devastator Batman by
Barbados to basically travel to this
tuning fork and to capture it to
essentially take it and bring you
directly to Barbados himself so we can
channel all of his energies into
recreating the multiverse as he sees fit
now on the surface it seems pretty
straightforward right like on the
surface it seems like all these
different Batman come from the Dark
multiverse and their goal is to
basically corrupt the the positive
multiverse and make it just like their
own but because of the fact that it was
basically all hands on deck in response
to the fact that we had all these
different versions of the Dark Knight's
showing up in attacking virtually
everybody almost every single superhero
responded the Justice League of America
Batman's own justice league team the
main Justice League itself the flash
Green Arrow Green Lantern
whole nine yards they all basically
responded as best they could now in
Justice League of America which is
actually a series that we haven't really
covered yet save for the prelude issues
basically the one shot to the characters
who were brought into the team Lobo is
part of that team and Lobo is a really
cool character he was kind of like DC's
answer to Wolverine in the sense that
Lobo was designed to be over the top he
was designed to be crazy and goofy and
just this super hardcore guy you could
imagine him just riding around in space
on his motorcycle
blasting Metallica so I mean it was kind
of cool but the whole idea is that he is
a character who in a lot of ways is on
par with Superman he's a powerhouse he
was designed to be the sort of muscle of
the Justice League of America team in
the sense that when Batman and his group
show up to a conflict and it requires
just brute force to overcome an enemy
Lobos the guy you send in but him going
against Devastator Batman is a pretty
interesting scenario because as far as
I'm aware I do not believe we've seen a
story where Lobo has fought doomsday
one-on-one in fact I don't know if
they've ever fought I'm not gonna swear
to that if there is a story let me know
because we'll cover it but nonetheless
this is an interesting scenario but the
other half of this is that it also gives
us this idea the Devastator is able to
overcome some of the most powerful
beings that are in the DC Universe and
so in a lot of ways he's the powerhouse
of the Dark Knights of Barbados as
forces and so what we end up doing is we
actually pick up about a day before in
Metropolis itself and we actually end up
joining Jimmy Olsen and Lois Lane and
this is kind of funny exchange here
because Jimmy also has been reading like
all these conspiracy theories in terms
of what's going on all these dark
knights popping up things like that Lois
Lane's response stop reading the
internet you know I guess never go to
internet comm I have no idea what the
internet is a dangerous place but it's
one of these funny little scenarios
because when it comes to the character
of Jimmy Olsen
well I wouldn't necessarily say that
Lois Lane sees him as a son in a lot of
ways she plays like a motherly role tool
I mean not in the sense that like she
took him to raise she doesn't you know
feed him and different things like that
but she does look out for him and it's
always been that way ever since Jimmy
Olsen was first introduced to DC Comics
it took time you know it took several
years for that sort of a scenario to
unfold but it's always been that way to
a degree and so it's kind of cool to see
how this exchange is still maintained
but the other half is you have to
remember Lois Lane is struggling we
talked about how during the events of
Dark Knight's medal
- that Superman and Wonder Woman had
shown out to try to confront Batman and
stop him from going to this whole
process of trying to find a way to
defeat Barbados only to have Barbados
into the realm anyway and as soon as
that happened Superman and Wonder Woman
were basically stripped of their life
force and reduced down to almost a
catatonic state and then sent to be how
prisoners in the center of the Dark
multiverse and so as far as Lois Lane is
aware her husband's just gone but the
fact remains in the middle of her it is
kind of you know heading out and doing
whatever it is it Lois Lane does she's
met by this Devastator Batman and this
is cool because this gives us the side
of his powers that we don't normally see
by and large when it comes to these Dark
Knights of Barbados you know despite the
fact that they are basically some
version of Batman from an alternate
dimension they have been modified both
in terms of their powers and in terms of
their physical appearance to
differentiate them and make them a
little more menacing - but we couldn't
help but believe when the mask comes off
red death he looks like Bruce Wayne when
the helmet comes off of you know the
drought she looks like Bruce Wayne would
look like his a chick when these
different outfits and these different
uniforms come off they will look like
Bruce Wayne and it makes sense that
Devastator Batman is more of a
transitionary character which is to say
Bruce Wayne can become the Devastator as
opposed to him being stuck that way and
so it is kind of interesting because
what we end up finding out is this
really cool origin story in the sense
that in earth- 1 somewhere along the
line Superman just lost it and we don't
know why we don't know what caused this
and even within the story there's no
answer given here you know Devastator
Batman says we don't know what it was we
don't know if it was Lex Luthor who
exposed Superman to some version of red
kryptonite that mutated him in an
uncontrollable way we don't know if it
was like Brainiac who seized control of
him we have no clue what it was but for
some reason or another Superman snapped
and basically turned on Batman and all
the members of the Justice League
now again much like the other stories
that we've seen were not really told
what happened to the other members of
the Justice League
we're largely left to believe the
Superman killed him and he really saved
Batman for last but this is a massive
betrayal on the side of Bruce Wayne in
this negative one universe because
remember regardless of what universe
were talking about regardless of what
story were referencing for years and
years and years Batman as Superman were
the best of friends it wasn't until the
Dark Knight Returns that Batman and
Superman fought for the first time and
that became an on running theme of their
stories whenever there's some kind of a
reboot or whatever DC wants to just type
up
and they have the two of them fight each
other but when the new 52 first cropped
up it was the two of them getting to
know each other when DC we birth
happened it was the new Superman getting
to know Bruce Wayne it was always this
idea that as time progresses whenever
they first encounter each other it takes
time for their friendship to grow but
when it does they become the best of
friends
and so when you're Bruce Wayne and you
know your parents were killed but a
mugging gone wrong in Crime Alley and
Gotham City and you've been dealing with
that your entire life and then you find
probably the closest friend you're ever
gonna have who just suddenly ups one day
and betrays you and the rest of the
Justice League there's almost no coming
back from that it's a psychological
break that takes place in the mind
because it's really Bruce Wayne who
looks around and says I can really find
no happiness in this world and so it was
sort of ironic because while he does
have a kryptonite spear and while that
wouldn't necessarily be able to take out
Superman it's actually a genius turn of
events because for the most part that's
really the only thing Batman fans do
have when it comes to like Batman
beating Superman like well you know
Batman would fight Superman and it would
just keep going with a Superman would
just punch his head off or he would
punch a hole in him or he would throw
him in the Sun and it will not if Batman
had kryptonite and so it becomes this
sort of running gag it becomes this idea
of what uses Batman against Superman if
he doesn't have kryptonite on his side
and so this takes that entire argument
and flips it on his head and what ended
up happening is somewhere along the line
Batman basically created or in some form
adapted the doomsday strength now this
requires a little bit of conjecture and
sort of haphazard guessing on our part
in the sense that we can more or less
assume that the events of like did death
of Superman
probably happened in this negative one
universe which is to say doomsday was
created on Krypton eons before
Kryptonians arrived and became
super-smart and then just kind of you
know fell in stasis were sent to earth
and lived on earth and basically was
buried under the ground for you know
however many billions of years or
something along those lines
eventually wakes up he and Superman
fight both Superman and doomsday die and
then that's really about it we can
assume that happened we can just
basically sort of make that claim but
regardless the offense unfolded a little
bit differently in the sense that
following this presumed death of
Superman Batman basically duplicated the
doomsday strain now again there's a lot
of other scenarios that could have
unfolded here it could have been that
Batman discovered doomsday that may be
doomsday never did kill Superman
everybody else you know basically fought
alongside Superman and killed doomsday
but regardless of the reason Batman
basically took the doomsday strain and
with his own body and what this does is
it turned him into this this literal
wrecking machine that can destroy the
destroy you know Superman being able to
sort of expunge this kryptonite gas of
sorts take Superman out and weakens him
it allows Batman to kill him and from
this point that's when the psychological
snap basically crosses a line that Bruce
Wayne can't come back from but here's a
funny thing about this we get a lot more
of an expose from like The Dark Knight
of the Batman who lost didn't we do from
anybody else and this is cool because we
haven't really seen that too often right
like when it comes to this mysterious
version of the Batman who last probably
the most popular character of Dark
Knight's metal and the one character
everybody wants an origin story for but
he's basically just popped up at the end
of the story we get this whole origin
story of this character some events take
place you know and then this version of
Batman pops up and says hey what if I
could resent you with a world where
everything is you know opposite of this
and where you can achieve the one goal
you've been wanted to achieve and you
know so on and so forth basically
tapping into the desires of these evil
versions of Batman in this scenario
Devastator sees him and immediately
calls him out as the Joker and like the
Batman who last doesn't deny it and
that's the cool thing about this is
because we get these little tidbits
these little goodies they kind of go
into the story itself and they sort of
help to like push forward all these
theories that people have all these
ideas that people have on who the Batman
who laughs is I mean I think personally
that it's basically Batman from The
Killing Joke I think that it's a version
of Batman who killed the Joker at the
end of the story and then became the
Joker or its Joker who killed Batman and
then became Batman because Joker
realizes he needs Batman I have no idea
what the case may be but it is kind of
cool to basically speculate in to
experiment and these little bitty
conversations that are extended by a
couple lines kind of give us this a
little bit of beefing up of information
and again it allows our wildest
curiosities to run awry and so again
much like the other Batman who were out
there because of the fact that
Devastator his is basically
disillusioned with Superman in the sense
that he came to the belief that Superman
basically told everybody I will be your
savior I will be your bright shining
star I will be the being that will help
lead you into a better tomorrow because
of the fact that he's become
disillusioned with that was Superman
becoming a bad guy the Batman who laughs
basically says what if I told you
there's a universe where people don't
know who how evil Superman is they don't
know what you know but we can go there
and we can make them know we can show
them who Superman really is it's tapping
into the hatred for Superman that
Devastator has and so what this does is
it basically has Devastator align
himself immediately with a batman who
lasts joining the forces of barbados and
then invading earth zero during the
events of dark nights metal - so again
that's how all this stuff sort of wraps
around and comes back together again the
difference here is that when Devastator
batman effectively shook the hand of
Lois Lane what he did is he infected her
with this sort of doomsday virus in the
sense of what she's begun doing is she
turned herself into a carrier and as a
result she's basically spreading this
virus without the city not realizing it
it's an airborne strain everybody who
she comes into contact with infects
everybody else and because it's the city
of New York and because it's such a high
population density as she breathed
she infects other people who in turn
infect other people and so it's just
this strain that basically multiplies
exponentially and just spreads
throughout the city of New York like a
wildfire now you also have the arrival
of like Kara zor-el and you know Lana
Lang you have these members of the
Superman family who show up in their
efforts to try to defeat Devastator
Devastator Batman but they're no match
against him I mean they can't take him
on you know just because of the fact
that he is so incredibly strong and
incredibly powerful the funny thing
about this though is it also sees the
involvement of Jonathan Kent now when I
read this Lois Lane runs back into their
home she's like okay we got to activate
the safe room with a safer won't
activate because the patio doors open
and Jonathan Kent's hovering out there
and intends to jump into the fight now
let me tell you something I don't know
how I would react if Jonathan Kent died
I would probably cry I love Jonathan
Kent as a character he's one of my
favorite characters from DC rebirth kids
Superman Superboy he's just he's so
vibrant and he's so fun I mean he's
learning about what it means to be hero
and it's so funny to see him react you
know with like Damian Wayne different
things like that thankfully for us this
doesn't happen Lois Lane grabs his son
Yanks him back in throws him in the
panic room and locked the door because
she herself is starting to manifest into
doomsday now keep in mind the reason why
this matters is because it seems as
though Devastator Batman is unique unto
himself doomsday is basically a being
built for death and destruction that's
all he is that's all he wants to do and
so the implication here is that where
Bruce Wayne has this doomsday strain
injected into himself it allows him to
control it for anybody else who becomes
doomsday they won't be that lucky
they'll basically just become a variant
of doomsday and all they're gonna do is
you
tear things to pieces but this is crazy
because it's basically this idea that
Devastator Batman says that's the point
of all this you know grabbing this
tuning fork whisking it off to Barbados
it's him essentially saying this world
is going to come to grips with the fact
that Superman is not their Savior
because what's going to happen is while
all this is going on while all these
people are being transformed while the
world is burning down around them
they're all gonna look up and they're
gonna say where's Superman and with
Superman nowhere to be found
they're gonna lose hope they're gonna
lose faith and so when superman returns
assuming that everything goes back to
normal
don't turn their backs on it that's what
Devastator batman is hoping for and so
again it's interesting and it's really
intriguing because what happens is that
at the end of this origin this runs
directly into Dark Knight's medal three
four five and six it runs into this idea
of the events that follow up with
Barbados having this tuning fork and
using as cosmic energies to achieve
whatever it is that ends up coming next
but would that being said guys we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the rod core if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like crazy question crazy question
here who do you think would win in a
fight
Devastator Batman or Shazam had nothing
to do with this story Shazam is not seen
now hide or hair in the story but I'm
just curious who do you guys think would
win
Devastator Batman or Shazam let me know
post a comment down below because I'm
kind of curious and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]